[Music]  what's up bernie o'donnell back again  with another episode of the smart castle  so today i swung by to give the building  a whole new  look throwback style like it used to  look like  getting a new suit getting ready to open  up for the small castle as soon as we  can  check it out  this is what she used to look like back  in the mid  early 90s  [Music]  old gray a little black trim  an homage to the black and white of  clerks you know what i can do with that  i could do without the people in the  video store which ones  all of them check out that sign it's  really popping now baby  it's gonna be pretty cool looking real  good today  check out real soon out  [Music]  you